[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur des gonades tv
leçon spécial débutants avec ninon
bonjour nino point jours alors on va
voir aujourd'hui une leçon fondamentale
vraiment la finale peut-être la plus la
plus courante ce carême le plus souvent
et que les débutants ne savent pas gagné
c'est vrai qu'il n'y ait pas forcément
meilleur oui ça dépend c'est très très
ok au blanc au noir mais on voit trop
souvent des débutants qui pour elle a
gagné qui est mais qui rate le truc
parce qu'ils se trompent en fait ils ne
savent pas comment il faut gagner
on va voir ça c'est vraiment la finale
fondamental à connaître il faut
absolument que vous compreniez ce qui se
passe si la finale roi epyon contre eux
roi voilà alors là c'est une position
qu'on vous a mis ses hauts blancs de
jouer alors si c'était au noir de jouer
de la partie serait nulle sur la
meilleure défense est là c'est au blanc
de jouer il ya un seul coup qui gagne et
puis alors vous pouvez pas le savoir si
vous connaissez pas le truc que là il
faut vraiment connaître et comprendre ce
qui se passe donc c'est la fameuse règle
d'opposition comme on l'appelle donc
c'est un peu délicat a expliqué mais ça
ça concerne le roi c'est à dire un
ce qui ma première en face d'un autre
roi c'est lui qui gagne ou qu'il fait
une mule en général donc on va
d'ailleurs montré leur mère ou expliqué
donc c'est l'opposition faut mettre le
roy on va voir tout de suite le bon coup
pour les blancs c'est de jouer 3 3 voilà
c'est à dire que si on verra tout à
l'heure si vous remonterez d'abord la
bonne solution pour vous montrer prix ce
qui marche pas si le roi n'est pas
devant le pion en fait vous pouvez pas
gagner la partie
vous pouvez pas arriver à faire nam à la
fin vous ferez pas forcément vous n'avez
pas à faire pour il faut préparer le
chemin du pion on veut que le pion
puisse être je dirais préparé par le roi
et pour ça faut prendre ce qu'on appelle
l'opposition voilà donc ici l'opposition
est prise par les blancs en se mettant
roi contre roye ici et le roi noir doit
doit jouer alors où il joue par exemple
bref c est qu il faut bien une formule
qui vous quelque part et là on prépare
le chemin du pion en faisant trois des
quatre mois on prépare le chemin des
pions mais attention faudra pas je
voulais le pion trop vite parce que si
sinon mais on va pas me faire gagner
donc c'est qui est assez impressionnant
cyan rien juste en quoi rire ça plante
là en fait encore
un coup merci là en fait si c'est donc
très haut noir c'était le cas on dit que
ces gagnants
et si ces très hauts blancs c'est du
passé multi est assez étonnant pour les
débutants et selon monsieur uniquement
il faut vous expliquer un peu plus tard
comment est ce sera nul mais tout à fait
bon vivre à tout à leur hit savait très
simple alors ici au f5 roi ici des 4
regardez donc le roi près par le chemin
du pion toujours donc là c'est préparer
mais il faut le préparer presque
jusqu'au bout donc là si par exemple si
les noirs jouer bombay roi ici il n'y a
pas de problème le pion peut avancer
tout seul donc aujourd hui le pion et
après il faut aussi sur les rangs face
et on se voit sur le côté donc il faut
que les noirs empêche les sa part de 6
faut surtout pas jouer l'option louis 6
nuls encore si vous jouez le pion c'est
les noirs qui se mettront devant nous
trois et vous pourrez plus passée donc
il faut reprendre l'opposition en se
mettant faso c'est le seul correct c'est
le seul coup comme il y en a pas d'autre
donc il faut bien connaître la manoeuvre
roi décide par exemple
et regardez up de l'autre côté on
prépare toujours pareil le chemin du
pont plus loin vous préparer le chemin
de ce pion moins il y aura de problème
le roi a condamn
le pion sans laisser de trois voix
vraiment rester en face parce que chaque
fois on nous oblige à bouger soit gauche
à droite et c'est ça l'idée leroy
n'arrive pas à rester juste en face de
notre roi enfin quand on rentre pas
notre roi donc salée des recettes pour
les noirs et là toujours pareil si vous
jouez le coût des quatre ici ce sont les
noirs qui vont nous mettre devant de vos
trois et vous allez perdre la partie
vous n'allez pas gagner vous n'avez pas
gagné en californie alors ici roi
auxerre on se met encore en opposition
et toujours alors me direz si les noirs
avaient joué voir ici par exemple et
bien dans ce cas là vous aurez contribué
à préparer le chemin du pion et s'il
vient là là il n'y a pas de problème
pour jouer des codes puisqu'il peut pas
se mettre devant nos 3 voilà donc pour
ipsen donc 3e set
ces dernières vous repasser devant
tranquillement et / ou avec cette ope
vous re prépare et je manipule alors il
ya toujours un moment où il faut
s'arrêter par exemple s'il est noir
jouera aussi ça vous n'allez pas jouer
17 parce que là il va aller chercher
votre pays et vous le prendre donc la
maintenance il faut quand même je
voulais qu'ils ont mis là il peut pas
regarder il se mettre en face il ya pas
de problème donc ce roi f7 maintenant
vous pouvez pousser le pion et sirois 8
alors si évidemment s'il joue rompt et
fuit toujours pareil là vous faites çà
et là c'est fini
et là c'est fini parce qu'elle est le
pion passent toutes celles et d'avoir
entaché fini le roi le roi le roi
contrôler toutes les cases pour avancer
donc il ya pas de problème et on fait
trop messieurs dames et après donc le
seul coup qui permettraient de tenir un
peu sur huit et lorient c'est très
simple on reprend hop on peut se former
devant il faut jouer par exemple ou
encore une fois là c'est mon réveillon
encore une fois si c'était ça pourrait
être différent c'est très à nous au noir
mais là exactement nous obligent au plus
les noirs parce que c'est très haut noir
partir soit à gauche ou à droite et
c'est grâce à ça on gagne chaque fois
qu'on a comme il n'y a plus rien à jouer
on est obligé à bouger et où naissait la
route et regarder et là hop et voilà
c'est fini
je crois que la même on a bien compris
puisque là ça y est il n'y a plus rien
qui pourra poser qu'est le canada s'est
assuré le roi ne peut plus se mettre
devant le pion donc on peut c'est fini
on passe c'est un problème et d'amea
prebon
après vous savez mater on vous renvoie
la leçon spéciale comment mater avec une
tour windham
c'est un peu pareil pour être trop et ça
c'est très rapide
alors qu'est ce qui se passe si on si on
se trompe au début donc par exemple si
si vous jouez le congo 3 et cette
précision c'est très important dans
cette ligne voilà donc là c'est fini il
suffit pour les noirs tout simplement de
se mettre devant le pion regardez vous
serez obligé alors on recule toujours
sur la case ici il faut pas reculer sur
les côtés ça peut poser des problèmes
surtout la fin et dès qu'on revient hop
vous mettez en face et vous allez voir
que les blancs au final alors hop
j'étais bien obligé de monter si vous
les protégez votre europe les noirs
prennent l'opposition et vous allez voir
qu'à la fin mais vous allez ne pas
pouvoir gagner parce qu'il y aura donc
la savoyarde est toujours là c'est très
important parce que sinon sinon ça
regardez si si vous vous déplacez ici là
par contre c'est une erreur puisque roy
sait les blancs qui prennent aux
positions sur la dernière rangée si
c'était plus tard ce serait pas grave
trop pour les noirs mais là là ça grave
parce qu'on joue au set et là on est
obligé de sortir et après y avoir cette
recette est c'est fini on peut
qu'empêcher dame donc la bonne défense
à ce moment là tout simplement c'est
toujours pareil venir en 8 es là si les
blancs jouent par exemple trois des six
eh bien on se met en face hélas les
blondes pas d'autre solution que de
pousser des six pourraient être 200 av
c'est la même façon voilà est sûre après
3,8 force et recel
on n'a pas aller de laisser le pion et
ses pattes voilà donc vous comprenez que
si le 6 le roi noir et devant juste au
contact du pion et vous pouvez pas
prendre l'opposition et vous pouvez pas
préparer le chemin du pion et ça bloque
donc de nice dès le début le borgou
c'est bien de venir devant le roi oui
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre si nous
pourrait tenir facilement pour pas se
perdre
dans ses explications c'est peu importe
si vous jouez avec les noirs cette
position avec les plantes et celle ci s
est toujours placé le roi juste en face
l'adversaire c'est vraiment l'importante
soi même pour les noirs pour faire
annuler pour le plan pour gagner c'est
qu'il ya le première juste place et le
roi justin pas là le premier qui sait
lui qui se dit bon ben alors il faut il
faut tempérer parce que si imaginons une
position là je vous mets une autre
position des places je déplace les trois
ans piscine voilà c'est déjà voilà mais
c'est toujours gagnant les noirs assez
alors les noirs pourraient prendre
l'opposition mais c'est une fausse
opposition parce que je peux toujours
jouer un coup d'attendre huit donc pas
aux quatre évidemment là on a une
chanson entre guillemets parce que on
est encore un coût supplémentaire
voilà on a en réserve voilà parce que le
puits n'était donc on passe la main en
quelque sorte on passe la même et
surtout pas un cadre parce que si vous
allez en quatre ce roi au cices vous
pourrez pas vous mettre en face donc
vous jouez 2,3 et sikhs antivirus is up
ont gagné en quatre et il n'y a pas de
problème donc toujours le pion derrière
le roi si vous avez compris sa
collection a toujours été dernier droit
et que vous devez gagner l'opposition
après c'est facile hein comprenez la
manoeuvre hop hop et vous reprenez à
chaque fois l'opposition le plus loin
possible et s'il monte là là vous pouvez
monter les pions tant qu'il peut pas
venir là ça va donc voilà c'est la
manoeuvre c'est reconnaître c'est pas si
compliqué que ça
vous allez gagner beaucoup de parties si
vous apprenez bien cette manoeuvre parce
qu'il ya énormément de partis surtout
chez les débutants qui finissent oui sur
ce type de finale oui ça arrive souvent
et qui malheureusement ne serait pas
voilà n'arrive pas à gagner parce qu'ils
ne comprennent pas cette manoeuvre
subtil d'opposition je crois qu'avec ça
et la finale retour contre moi qui ai la
finale la plus basique à connaître
comment mater avec une tour si vous avez
ça au moins vous avez des bases qui font
que vous allez battre n'importe quel
débutant ou un échec donc celle ci a
remarqué ça marche c'est la même manière
sur les autres colons sofa a et h
c'est à dire c'est absolument la même
chose c'est puis on était placé sur aube
et ses volontés quatre c4 simple c'est
le même avec l'opposition d'un porto ça
marche pas sur les colos ayache sur sa
marche pas parce que vous pouvez pas
envoyer le roi de l'autre côté des
chiens quand le pion et sur la colonne a
ici où se fait sur cette colonne ici ou
alors la colonne aoula coach vous avez
un problème parce que le roi noir quand
il est coincé ici il peut pas s'échapper
à gauche et là il peut pas s'échapper à
droite ce qui fait que ça marche plus il
faut que l'on soit sûr tout n'importe
lesquels des autres colonnes ça marche
mais pas sur celle ci si vous savez 1,8
avoir plus d'informations sur sept nuls
théorique hongroise sur un autre court
sur les nuls théorique d'ailleurs on est
envahis streit oui tout à fait il ya
toutes les amériques
la leçon spéciale sur l'une théorique
pour pour bien comprendre comment
fonctionne perron est annulé exactement
merci nino pour cette démonstration la
finale essentielles à connaître roi
epyon contreras à connaître pour tous
aux débutants aux échecs et même pour le
joueur expérimenté qui des fausses ou
trompeuses
oui bon courage à tous les débutants et
les joueurs merci puis je vous dis à
bientôt sur des gondoles tv au revoir
[Musique]